thanks so much for having me
so as uh it was just mentioned I'm
talking about generative AI which is all
the rage but how it can actually be
useful uh not just something that high
schoolers use to cheat on their essays
um
so just to talk about an agenda I'll
continue with a little bit more of an
introduction to myself and how seat came
to be kind of the origin story
um talk a little bit about what is a
natural language interface for data what
is it and why is it important and also
how did it come to be what is the
history leading up to natural language
interface for data
um I'll talk a little bit about how
businesses can actually use natural
language interfaces for data some of the
challenges associated with not just
building natural language interfaces but
also using them
and just kind of wrap things up with uh
where I think things are at right now
um maybe I'll just come over here so
a little bit about seek
um so I am our original founder and our
CEO
um I started seeing about a year and a
half ago
uh you know as you heard before that I
was a data scientist for many years and
before that an astrophysicist
um was at Citadel uh most recently
before starting seek leading a dating
team
um and uh as you can see you know we
have a lot of other data nerds uh
leading our team
um
so what kind of led me to start seek I
actually kept experiencing this pain
Point pretty much everywhere I worked it
all started you know my first two weeks
on the job as a Quant
um this was my very first job ever just
fresh out of grad school and I was
supposed to be working on trading
algorithms but you know I was just
sitting at my desks literally week two
and a sales person comes up to me and is
like hey Sarah this client needs these
stats on these algorithms you know can
you just get this for me
and I was like what are you asking me to
do like you want me to like go into
Sequel and do a bunch of addition and
subtraction to get these stats for you
like you can't you don't have the tools
to get this yourself and it's like yeah
that was the case so it's just not what
I was expecting
um that I would have to just calculate
all this stuff for non-technical people
and what was crazy was you know 10 years
later I realized this wasn't just a
fluke like I had to do this every single
place I worked but there's just no
alternative uh you know there are no
tools that could do this for me so just
had to do it myself
um and so I kind of just came to accept
it as the status quo
um but everything changed when I saw
gpt3
this was three years ago believe it or
not almost and you know just seeing it
generate code it made me realize wow you
know this is going to change a lot about
how people work with data and so I'm
going to talk a little bit more about
all this as I go through the talk
um but just to kind of get to the next
slide a little bit more about seek like
I mentioned we're a year and a half old
um we are based in New York although we
have employees in Cupertino uh Portland
Baltimore
um we've raised seven and a half million
from Battery Ventures and conviction the
new fund from Sarah Gua of Greylock we
were actually their first investment
we have customers ranging from startups
all the way to the Fortune 100
and we actually have a pretty serious AI
team uh from all these top institutions
so
chat GPT uh
can I scan a show of hands who of you
have heard of chat GPT in this
conference
how many people have actually used chat
GPT
I mean almost everybody
so
why why is why is it so so hyped like
what's what's the big deal about it is
it just hype is it just a bubble what is
it
um
what really struck me the most was kind
of some of these examples it can pass
the bar exam it can pass the sommelier
exam
I don't know which is more impressive
it can Crush all the AP tests except for
English which is still getting I guess a
four
or whatever it is
it can build a website
so
you know these are very impressive uh
stats to me and the reason for the hype
is because it's good
so to talk a little bit about why is it
good
um I want to talk a little bit about my
first exposure to natural language
processing which was 2019 I was a data
scientist
um someone put me on a problem where I
had to learn NLP and I actually didn't
know anything about NLP so I took this
class uh Stanford cs224n just looked at
the free content
and what I remember seeing in 2019
was this slide and it really struck me
like I circled the part at the bottom
that really struck me the most if you
fully solved co-reference arguably
you've solved AI like what does that
mean
um what they're saying in these slides
in this class at Stanford was if you can
solve this problem called co-reference
resolution which basically means in a
sentence mapping all of the right
Expressions to the same entity as shown
they're saying you've solved Ai and I
just saw that and I was like wow that is
a bold statement to make like I better
listen to that
um so I'm not saying this is my opinion
I'm just saying this is what I saw in
this class at Stanford in 2019.
so going back to this example to do all
this stuff you I mean co-reference
resolution is table Stakes like you know
mapping the same expressions in a
sentence to the same entity like
it's doing that and much more like it's
passing the bar exam so
um in my opinion the hype is very much
warranted for this reason
so I want to talk a little bit about
what existed before uh chat GPT and what
even existed before deep learning
um
you know the answer is statistics and
rules-based approaches
um so Google Translate is a really
interesting thing to talk about how they
transitioned from uh statistical methods
to deep learning
so what exactly is statistical machine
translation
um you know this is a technique that
existed before deep learning
it involves a lot of human Labor uh
modeling all of these different uh parts
and permutations of sentences mapping
different terms together and using
statistics
to model how it can map to another
language so it's very labor intensive it
involves a lot of just modeling by hand
and it involves a lot of people
so in 2016 Google switched to neural
machine translation which is deep
learning based
and this was a really interesting move
because with deep learning what they
realized is that it can learn a lot of
these rules and statistical
relationships and all this modeling you
can just learn it on its own and encode
it into its parameters so that is a
really big shift it means that something
now exists that's a model that is so
seamless that it doesn't require a bunch
of statisticians to do all this modeling
it can just do a lot of this on its own
without so much human labor
and so this is why deep learning was
really important for Google Translate
so where does data come in and where
does the natural language interface for
data come in well the reason I talked
about Google Translate is because
there's analogies in the world of data
and the natural language interface for
data so I'm going to talk about what
exactly is a natural language interface
for data
this is a picture from SQL Server
1996. so this is 20 years before Google
switched to deep learning for Google
translate and this idea of a natural
language interface has existed for much
longer than you know way before 1996
like this idea has been around in the
80s if not before the 80s
um so what is it
um
you know someone asked a question
into their
1996 machine cathode ray tube Monitor
and all
how many of product X were sold in
Washington in the last year
so you're asking a question that
presumably you need some structured data
to answer
a natural language application comes in
and does some calculations
some SQL here gets generated some sort
of code doesn't have to be SQL could be
other languages
it's querying a database in this case
SQL Server
and getting the answer back to the
person that asked the question
so you're talking to your data with
natural language
and this is actually existed you know
like this this picture is from something
that I believe is called English query
that's actually SQL server has had since
1996 and maybe even before
um
but you know as I showed with Google
translate you know the issue is just the
stuff just didn't work right like
SQL is hard SQL generation is really
really hard
um and so you know with traditional
statistical methods
um it's kind of questionable how useful
is this going to be
um you know and the answer is this this
has been the dream for a really long
time but the methodologies really didn't
work that well and I'll show that with
this uh chart
so in 2021
um you know two years after kind of
being exposed to NLP for the first time
um
I saw
um this happening so what what's going
on in this chart
in 2020
the state of the art
machine learning model
couldn't solve a single question from
this data set called the human eval data
set which is a data set that measures uh
coding ability
so uh this is this goes back to the
previous slide like people have dreamed
of things like natural language
interface for a long time but
um the technology just wasn't there and
so that is evident here even in 2020 the
state-of-the-art Deep learning model
couldn't even answer a single question
but as you can see throughout 2021 these
models kept getting better and better
and it just exploded
um like looking at 2021 the state of the
art model could get 72.3 of these
questions correct
um and so this chart really just shows
back in 2021 August
um that's when we were really seeing an
inflection point in the ability of deep
learning models to generate code and a
big reason for that going back to chat
GPT is large language models
um the same models that power chat GPT
you know I'm sure everyone here already
knows this but Chad GPD can also write
code
um and it's actually the best uh model
out there at cogeneration so this is
from 2021 but the models have only
gotten better
yeah
okay so enough talking about the
technology and how it's evolved
um I want to talk a little bit now about
the business side of
why are natural language interfaces
needed and what problems are they
solving so I already told you a little
bit about why I started seek
um but I want to go a little bit more
into the actual problem
so uh you know questions are getting
asked to the data Team all the time
hey data team sorry to bug you but can
you just pull these stats on these
customers I cover you know I want to
make sure that I prevent them from
churning or whatever it is and that's
when you go through this manual manual
work
of going into your snowflake or other
cloud data warehouse
you type out some SQL maybe you try to
look across all the SQL you've written
in the past and find some code that may
be similar what you wrote
um you know and you generate all this
code on your own
um you might open up some sort of ticket
maybe you work with jira and you know a
lot of questions come in and you
maintain them all with these jira
tickets
and finally you put it into matplotlib
or whatever visualization tool you're
using chart it out and then by the time
you've actually gotten around to all
this
this is probably not the only question
you're getting you know you're probably
getting these questions from a lot of
people in in the business and so if
these questions have piled up
um you know one month later maybe you
finally got around to this ticket and uh
you get back to the customer success
person or whoever it was that asked you
the question and they say thanks but I
just made the decision without the data
sorry
um or Worse most of the customers just
churned
so seek solution is a natural language
interface that business users can ask
questions to and be able to get the data
that they need much faster and be able
to ask more questions
so this is an example of a customer
success manager asking seek a question
and just typing in the question that
they want to have answered
and behind the scenes the way that seek
works is we are doing code generation to
query the data and so this is where
generative AI comes in
um like I mentioned before it's not a
Magic Bullet
um it's still not feasible to build a
thin wrapper around gpt4 and have a
magical natural language interface for
data you know it's still a hard problem
but it's a hard problem that we are
solving with generative AI as a piece of
it in addition to other things like
other models and
um a great user interface
um just to talk a little bit more about
the problems that we're solving and you
know the value that a natural language
interface can add
something that we've seen is that
sometimes there's actual Revenue that
can be blocked because you just don't
have the data or the data analyst
power that you need to be able to answer
all your questions
so in this example something that we
learn is actually within cpg companies
you know very large ones
there's a lot of products that they
actually can't ship online because each
of these products has regulations and
being able to get the data for those
regulations so that they can make the
decision to ship these products there's
just not enough data analysts to analyze
all these products and deem that they're
able to be shipped so as a result a lot
of products actually just sit around in
warehouses or brick and mortar stores
that could be shipped and could be
generating Revenue
and we actually learned that this is
hundreds of millions if not billions of
dollars of gmv that just could be
unlocked if you had the data team you
know a bigger data team like much bigger
working on it and so this is an example
of how a natural language interface you
can just ask these questions and get the
data for more products this is an
example of an increase in Roi that a
company would be able to get
so um
just to talk a little bit more about
other benefits you know you can
get questions answered much faster than
would be possible without AI
you can ask more questions so our
customers have res thousands of
questions
and you don't have to wait two weeks
anymore to get an answer to a basic
question that could help you tomorrow
you can get answers much faster
so these are some of the benefits that
businesses will achieve with a natural
language interface
for data
Okay so
I know everyone is you know dated people
so I'm sure there's a lot of cynics in
here so this is for you guys
um what are the limitations of a natural
language interface
um
I think it's helpful to talk about
what's realistic today with the natural
language interface
um you know right now we're really at
data q a which is like I Illustrated it
is already adding a lot of value but
there's a lot more that can be done in
the future too so I want to talk a
little bit about where this is all going
um right now
um we're at a stage where you can ask
questions for example how many
transactions did we have in Montreal
and be able to get the data that you
need back fast
but in the future we'll be able to help
with higher and higher level business
questions for example not just how many
transactions did we have in Montreal but
should we build a brick and mortar store
in Montreal
and imagine asking that and getting real
data back that is correct in addition to
pros and cons supported by the data
that's a higher level task that is still
data driven but also has a more uh
concrete point of view
moving on
um imagine if you could just ask should
we build a brick and mortar store and
instead of just getting the pros and
cons you actually get an answer yes or
no with the pros and cons
so
this is an example of kind of going from
answers to more you know what you could
call wisdom
um and this is where we see natural
language interfaces for data continuing
to add value in the future
okay so this is a really gnarly
challenge here
um you know going back to the SQL Server
example if you're generating SQL to
answer questions about data this is one
of the biggest challenges
um SQL queries realistically are not
clean like if you look at this example
um you know it's like four lines of SQL
um that's that's not real life
um
like this is real life
um I personally have worked at companies
where they were literally 3 000 line SQL
queries
um and so how do you even generate that
much SQL and
you know it's just this is a really big
challenge that if you're just again you
know building a thin wrapper around gpt4
it's not going to generate 3000 lines of
correct SQL there's a lot more work and
Engineering involved to actually get
this to work
so it's a hard problem that actually
hasn't been 100
um automated yet in a way that can
perform at this level of quality
another example is how do you know you
can trust the output I think this is the
real elephant in the room
um I'm going to talk a little bit about
this example so this is an older model
of GPT I actually asked it to gpt4 today
and it it you know it gave a much better
answer actually
um so this is more of an example the
models have actually gotten better
but um somebody asked you know when did
France gift Lithuania the Vilnius TV
Tower
and it just answered France gifted
Lithuania the villainous TV tower in
1980 and that's just not right
um it was actually sponsored by the
Soviet Union and built in Lithuania
so I don't know if it got it mixed up
with like the Statue of Liberty or what
but it's not right
um so this is an example of you know
what people call hallucinations of the
models
um you can't just throw a generative AI
model at a problem and let it just rip
like you need some guard rails in place
to ensure that it works and in our world
the data world
it's completely unacceptable to ever
deliver bad data to the decision makers
so the bar is really really high
and that's why that this makes a natural
language interface for data a very
valuable problem but also a very hard
problem
so talking a little bit about where the
space is going
um
this is the way that we see people
working with data in the future
um this is a picture of Iron Man working
with Jarvis
um hopefully it'll look this cool
someday
um but you know the workflow like
imagine just querying data with your
voice
um like hey seek pull up this data and
you can tell it whatever Transformations
you need
and then just add some more data on top
um this is really where we see the
workflow going in the Futures being able
to just query data very easily without
needing to know anything about the data
and certainly not having to bother the
data team so the data team can be
working on tasks that also add value to
the business that only they can work on
like cleaning the data and discovering
in my case I come from the hedge fund
world and trading world so in my case it
would have been I would have loved to
have more time to just mine through the
data and discover insights that could
make our company money you know what we
call Alpha that's a that's an example
that's personal to me and every business
has that example of those hard problems
that only the data team can solve that
they just can't get to right now
so in conclusion a couple things
the first thing is the quality of
natural language interfaces is higher
than ever before
and a lot of this goes a lot of the
credit goes towards deep learning and in
particular this much hyped generative AI
like it's not just hype you know it
actually is adding real value to
businesses to get more insights from
their data today
um so that's the first thing
the second thing is there are a lot of
challenges involved working with
generative AI especially for data and
working with natural language interfaces
for data and so those of you that are
considering working with this kind of
Technology
um
I hope that it was helpful that I laid
out some of the challenges that you
should consider especially as you think
about your stack and how these kinds of
platforms fit in
um and for those of you who you know are
thinking of building with this
technology I hope that it it helped you
um kind of understand the challenges as
well
but in conclusion those of you who do
decide to adopt natural language
interfaces for data to your Tech stack
will result in a business that enjoys
more accessibility to data than ever
before
thank you
[Music]